all right great our next speaker is
Christina Liggett Hebrew University and
Caltech she's gonna talk about accuracy
first even though this is the last talk
sadly for the workshop the workshop
priorities are different I Christy's
last breath hi great thanks for having
me the experts really interesting
workshop thanks for all the organisation
to everyone at Simons for making this
happen so
I the motivation for this talk is as we
all know so first I should say this is
joint work with folks at Penn Seth Neil
Aaron Ross Bogner Stephen Wu will appear
nips and the motivation for this talk is
that as we all know lots of interesting
things these days happen on individuals
potentially sensitive data so you know
it's you know how does Facebook decide
what to show us how does Google steer
our attention how did the ads that we
see get chosen you know how do we get
online driving directions how do we get
product recommendations how's it decided
whether or not we get a loan and you
know many many things and it's just sort
of this this lot of interesting things
being done with our potentially personal
information and there are a lot of
reasons why we might care about privacy
and we've heard earlier this week that
we you know maybe even instead of saying
privacy should say robustness or
stability but I'll say privacy for the
purposes of this talk but so why why
should we care about privacy and and
beyond our interest in robustness and
stability there there's privacy for in
some sense privacy sake so privacy for
legal or regulatory requirements privacy
to avoid getting in trouble and having
your hands on data that you don't want
to have either because you're worried
about leaks or subpoenas privacy for the
purposes of sort of brand identity or
public perception which is maybe what we
see in some applications of differential
privacy technology but for for many
reasons we might be interested in
imposing a robust instability privacy
type of guarantee on our computations
and in some cases
it's really privacy first or we might
hope that it would be privacy first or
robustness first or stability first that
the we have a sort of well understood in
some sense literature at this point
talking about when you have a privacy
requirement that's binding or a
stability requirement that's binding for
your computation how can we go about
minimally impacting accuracy of the
computation and sometimes that's the
environment that you're really in where
privacy is first but in other cases it's
really not and I think in many
situations it's not that we come with a
privacy or stability requirement for a
computation but we have maybe an
accuracy requirement for computation and
privacy is nice if we can get it and so
in this work we're looking at that side
of the question so how can we understand
the best privacy of stability guarantees
that we can give for algorithms subject
to accuracy goals and so we've already
seen the differential privacy in this
workshop but I'll just do a quick recap
to remind us of what is this stability
notion that we'll be talking about and
then hi you're all familiar I assume
with empirical risk minimization but
I'll just mention that there's been very
nice work that's been done in sort of
the privacy first or stability first
perspective on erm and then I'll talk
about how do we go about making more
accuracy first so what do we mean when
we say privacy or stability here so sort
of informally the the goal is I to say
that access to the results of my
computation shouldn't let anybody learn
much more about somebody then they could
have learned if we've done the same
analysis submitting that individual for
the database and so you know we've we've
seen this before so just go quickly
through this with the intuition here so
if we have some true computation that we
want to do on a data set then we think
about sort of randomizing it in some
sense and
you know sort of intuitively what we're
gonna do is we're gonna induce a
distribution over the outcome space
that's just hopefully and well
concentrated around the correct answer
but has a little bit of spread to it and
in the promise that we would like to get
for an individual is that if you were to
leave the database then no outcome would
change probability by very much this is
a property of that mapping from database
space to outcome spaces stability
property and so formally the
differential privacy model is a
statistical database model where what
we're thinking about a database as forms
of entries from some set of possible
rows one row per person and the analyst
wants to compute on such a database and
preserve the privacy of individuals so
we want to design some randomized
algorithm that's going to map from
database space into outcome space to
mask small changes in the underlying
input database and so what do we mean
when I say small changes the the usual
notion here is that we want to require
nearly identical behavior and databases
that differ by the addition or removal
of a single row and so given that we can
talk about this stability property of a
computation which is just to say that
for any pair of neighboring data sets D
and D prime and for any subset of the
outcome space you might be interested in
the probability theory algorithm will
map the first database into that subset
of the outcome space is going to be very
close in this differential privacy's and
near-net nearness sense ID to the
probability that we'll see an outcome in
that subset I under the neighboring
database D prime we think about this as
being some small multiplicative
difference and sometimes we also will
talk about some it's an additive
difference but just thinking back to our
intuition is this is basically saying
that as you fix the behavior of your
algorithm want some particular input
database and it imposes constraints on
the behavior of your algorithm one
unsimilar databases okay and then
thinking just since we haven't been
thinking about privacy for privacy sakes
so much this week thinking about the
perspective of an
individual eye considering whether or
not to submit their data or participate
truthfully in a computation who's I who
enjoys where the computation enjoys a
guarantee of differential privacy the
individual might might be hesitating
because of concern about particular
outcomes or consequences that might
occur may be immediately we were down
the line as a result of this computation
being done and what differential privacy
says to that individual is well if you
identify those potential bad outcomes
and think about them and what what are
the odds that they will occur if you've
participated in the computation
well actually they'll they'll occur with
almost exactly the same probability if
you were to withhold or lie about your
information so the stability property
gives some guarantee to individuals or
significant threat to individuals that
about the same things will happen
regardless of whether or not you
participate like imagined we also
sometimes talk about this epsilon-delta
parametrized version of the stability
notion where we have not just a
multiplicative change in the
probabilities but also an additive Delta
change and we've seen some properties of
the stability notion already but I'll
just remind you if the ones that are
most relevant to us today so the first
of these is post-processing
which just intuitively says that any
subsequent computations and the results
of a differentially comprised of a
computation maintain the privacy or
maintain the stability and then the one
that we've seen a lot of emphasis on of
course is this composition notion so
intuitively just to remind you what
composition is telling us is that if we
run a multiple differentially private
algorithms we can still reason about the
overall stability so very informally
this is a statement that the Epsilon's
and the deltas add up in some sense and
this is very nice for the reasons that
we've seen so far this week but also
just because it's it allows us to do a
very simple privacy analysis of even of
potentially very complex algorithms sort
of related to some of the themes we saw
earlier today and and this is
particularly powerful and gives us sort
of the the Knights adapter data analysis
we've seen earlier because these
guarantees of composition hold even if
subsequent computations are chosen as a
function of previous results and so
because there's not the focus here we'll
just sort of take take the the
composition guarantees is given but this
is really sort of what makes
differential privacy tick it's what
makes differential privacy such a nice
notion is that it lets us build up more
sophisticated algorithms from these very
simple building blocks and perhaps the
simplest building block so the simplest
differential private algorithm is the
Laplace mechanism which is just a name
for the direct addition of Laplace noise
so this is a way of achieving a
differential privacy guarantee on a
numeric computation and so the the
amount of noise that that you need to
add scales with the sensitivity of the
computation so how much that computation
can change if you add or remove one
person from a input database so this
this building block is going to be sort
of the the essential building block that
we'll need for our discussion today and
all the mechanisms that we'll talk about
our belts using the support for the
pause mechanism so right so what do we
want to do today so again lots of
interesting computations on personal
data
what are these interesting computations
well some examples and maybe somebody
wants to learn to predict what gel-type
maybe somebody wants to learn to predict
what adds you'll click on maybe somebody
wants to learn to predict what you'll
buy it's basically there's a lot of
extrapolation from lots of data of rules
that map individual behavior into
specific outcomes and so a very natural
place to start our investigation of
thinking sort of accuracy first is to
think about different so five private
learning in a particular empirical risk
minimization so we'll know the setting
here is that there are true labels from
points drawn from an underlying
distribution and the Aluna has access to
some try
well data and they need to pick a
hypothesis I from some given set to
minimize service ticks in the training
set and hopefully this is going to give
this good results on the underlying
distribution and there's been a lot of
work on differentially private erm and
and basically what we're doing here is
building on a lot of a lot of what's
going on here but basically at some
level what's happened is people have
thought about all the different places
that you can put her existing erm
algorithms and have tried them all so
you can you can perturb the data you can
perturb the objective you can protect
the output you can perturb the procedure
you can basically anywhere you can add
the noise in some sense people have
tried to add the noise and it have
analysed the consequences here
like our entities for privacy and the
impacts on the accuracy of these
algorithms and so that's all it feels
like my question has already been
addressed we have all these theorems
that talk about privacy accuracy
trade-offs why don't they talk about
accuracy privacy trade-offs I mean isn't
that the same thing and yes you can take
any one of these theorems that you like
and you can flip it so what do I mean by
a flip it so you could take an existing
utility theorem and you could solve for
the smallest epsilon that achieves
whatever accuracy requirement you have
in mind and then you could run your
algorithm with the corresponding epsilon
and that would achieve what I'm setting
out to achieve here it would be sort of
an accuracy first approach to performing
privacy-preserving empirical risk
minimization and it's you know it's a
completely sound approach but it's maybe
not as good as it could be so why not
well existing utility theorems are
really worse case statements and
algorithms often may provide better
accuracy privacy than they promise it's
one of the issues is that we have some
sort of sloppy consonants that haven't
necessarily been been optimized away and
then maybe sort of the more interesting
issue in some sense is that a specific
data set or a specific outcome sort of
property of of the outcome that you
actually have on your data might allow
for better privacy utility trade-offs
than these worst case theorems would
tell you and so it's possible that
you're giving up a lot by just flipping
one of these theorems and picking the
corresponding epsilon the question is
can we ever do better can we sort of
find our way to understanding when there
is a better trade-off in our particular
situation so it feels like this ought to
be really straightforward it feels like
we ought to be able to just go around
trying values of epsilon until we get
one that works and so just try an
epsilon does this satisfy our accuracy
constraint no okay here's another
epsilon trumping see if it satisfies
their accuracy constraint oh oh that was
maybe more than we needed
and just sort of search in epsilon space
and it's the basis of an idea that works
but there's some problems some issues
with that approach and this sort of
basic issue here is that that search in
epsilon space is a data dependent search
and so if you want to do a careful
privacy analysis here you would have to
pay for all of those different epsilon
that you tried even though you only in
the end used one of them the path that
took you to that epsilon is a costly one
this is not a familiar way of thinking
about things if you're not coming from
sort of
differential privacy perspective and it
feels sort of very overly cautious to
make me pay for every epsilon along the
way and the question is did I really
need to pay for all of those epsilon
along the way until I found a good one
for my accuracy goal and that's sort of
a unless sort of fundamental issue at
some level but an important one is is
that we don't actually have language to
talk about privacy losses that are a
function of the data so it's not really
uh pretty clear how did bound privacy
loss when you do this kind of searching
the search could run for a long time and
then eventually we get some guarantee
how do we talk about that guarantee so
we need a language there for speaking
about data dependent privacy guarantees
so basically the for the rest of my talk
I'll tell you about how to do a
principled version of this epsilon
search idea that addresses these issues
basically what we do is we give you a
meta method for doing this search that
will be applicable to several classes at
private learning algorithms and then
I'll show you briefly how this performed
really I just want to give you the
intuition for how we address those
particular issues that came up when I
tried to sort of do epsilon search
before and and then sort of show you
that it seems to be working and and a
couple of existing issues that remain so
the high level approach is initially
what we'd like to do is we'll compute a
very private hypothesis and then we're
going to degrade the privacy of that
hypothesis
using a doubling approach until the
accuracy guarantee is met so basically
it's gonna be this idea of searching in
an epsilon space but to avoid paying
extra to avoid paying for all of the
absalon's that we try along the way
we'll use noise across our rounds that's
correlated so that effectively you can
subtract noise from a previous round to
get the next round it's going to allow
us to avoid paying for each time and
then in order to I allow us to check and
pay appropriately in terms of privacy
check whether our accuracy guarantee has
been met we come up with a new algorithm
to address that issue in the end we're
able to only pay the privacy costs of
the final hypothesis so those earlier
Epsilon's you tried are free but we do
have to pay for the checking the
checking at each round whether or not
you've actually picked in a suitable
epsilon in terms of your accuracy goal
okay so and then we have this issue of
how do we talk about these guarantees so
this approach doesn't satisfy any sort
of a priori epsilon differentially
private
I guarantee for any fixed epsilon but if
it terminates after K runs it seems to
satisfy some sort of bounded privacy
loss text post and so I this is related
I to ideas that come out in this work of
Rogers Roth Ullman and be done known as
privacy of dominators there that the
goal was to develop a theory of privacy
composition when the data analysts can
choose the privacy parameters of
subsequent computations as a function of
the outcomes of the previous
computations and sort of in this theme
excuse me the concept of expose privacy
loss and of expose differential privacy
guarantees excuse me who the notion is
defined raps pretty much as you would
expect so the act we talked about the
expose privacy lots of randomized
algorithm on an outcome so no privacy
loss it's specific to an outcome of of
the computation the maximum over pairs
of neighboring databases of the log of
this probability ratio such as the
probability that we'd select that
outcome under the the one database in
the probability if we that we select
that outcome under the neighbouring
database and now excuse me now we can
talk about an ex post differential
privacy guarantee of an algorithm and
the way we do that is by defining some
function that maps from outcome space to
some sort of quantification of the loss
and now we can say that we satisfying
this function of outcome ex post
differential privacy if for all outcomes
our loss is indeed bounded by this
function so now we have a language at
least for talking about expose privacy
guarantees now let's go back to trying
to achieve ex post differential privacy
so so I mentioned we have this approach
that allows us to not pay for every
round which is this notion of a
correlated noise so this is an idea that
comes out of a paper of khufu Jana Sun
and Papa so this year and the algorithm
here is that you look at a continuous
random walk that starts at your private
data such that the marginal distribution
in each point in time is the plus sign
charge at that and that true data with
variance increasing over time and so now
we have basically a sequence of points
where more private points can be derived
from the last private ones and in order
to get what we need we just need to
reverse this process
okay and so now we have the ability to
run multiple rounds that all enjoy sort
of less and less privacy and where we
can eventually sort of find our way to
the the right level of epsilon without
paying for the earlier ones okay so then
then we have this additional question of
sort of how do we check whether we're
done how do we check whether or not
we've satisfied the correct level of
accuracy and say okay we can stop so if
you're familiar with the literature
there there's an algorithm that sounds
like it's almost the right thing for us
here this this idea above threshold
which is just that I differentiate
private approach that lets us take a
data center in the sequence of
adaptability chosen queries and
privately output the first query that
exceeds a given threshold and this lets
you is an approach that lets you pay it
sort of exponentially less than you
would have if you paid the composition
of the queries for us we have a little
bit of a problem which is that our
queries are dependent on the data and so
naively we'd need to publish and pay for
them all and we'd like to avoid doing
that obviously so we don't have to have
to tell you details but basically we
come up with a a
slight tweak on this above threshold
algorithm that allows us to handle this
particular sort of adaptive query
setting and now we have the pieces that
we need to put together as sort of this
accuracy accuracy first approach so now
we have an algorithm that applies
actually to any erm take technique that
can be described as a post-processing of
a pause mechanism so for example out
perturbation where you add the pasta
noise to the result or covariance
perturbation where you're effectively
perturbing the data there Converter be
the covariance matrix close the data and
then optimizing using that noisy data so
these are two existing differential
private erm approaches on which you can
layer this accuracy first approach
and just in the next few minutes I want
to show you a little bit about how that
ended up working the summary is pretty
simple which is that I the approach
massively outperforms simply inverting
the theory curve so what I mean is
flipping the existing theorems the
corresponding SST terms and we also
improve on sort of a baseline epsilon
doubling approach where you actually do
the epsilon search but sort of pay for
it naively and so what does this look
like so we have a couple of settings so
we'll look at the first one here is a
ridge regression setting the prediction
of popularity of Twitter posts and here
so what are we looking at so we're
looking at this pot of the the XS arrow
guarantee so this is the the alpha that
we demand the accuracy that we demand
we're looking at the sort of
corresponding expose privacy loss that
were able to achieve and we're comparing
here a few different things so here we
have the theory curves both from the
covariance perturbation approach one
from the output perturbation approach up
here and we have here noise reduction so
just to sort of orient you privacy loss
is bad being down as good and the thing
that to maybe help you interpret you
know how good is this the thing to keep
in mind is that I perhaps the natural
way to think about privacy risk is
actually exponential in the epsilon so
these gaps are quite substantial in
terms of the impact on privacy risk and
so we see that there's some promise here
that perhaps I thinking in a slightly
more sophisticated way than just
flipping the theory curves can can get
you some benefit on a real-world problem
we see sort of similar results when we
look at another problem in this case is
the logistic regression problem
this is characterizing the event Network
events is malicious or in a
sent in the kdd 99 cup dataset and so
again here we see here we just have one
sort of theory curve that we're
comparing to we would see a benefit from
this approach and then now I want to do
this sort of comparison with a naive
epsilon doubling where you pay for
everything along the way going back
again to these two examples we here we
see a benefit it it feels like it's
maybe sort of lots of a benefit it is
less of a benefit but I still want to
point out that because of this
exponentiation of the epsilon I the
privacy risk that we seen here at alpha
of 0.05 is 10 under the noise reduction
approach and it's something like 500
under the doubling approach so this
these are perhaps significant eye
impacts on the privacy level that were
allowed that we're able to achieve and
similarly we see see for the little just
a quick cash in case so
I can show you some some other plots but
maybe first I'll sort of wrap up and
there are questions we can go to the
other plots but basically I there are
two things that are a little bit
unsatisfying here are a little bit
surprising here the first is that I
wasn't expecting all at all that this
the costs in terms of privacy of testing
whether or not we got the accuracy we
needed that that was going to be
substantial but then when we ran these
experiments we saw that testing was
really a dominant cost here and it's
possible that this is not real in the
sense that were empirical approach is
driven by sort of using it if you're a
theoretical bound on the maximum norm of
any hypothesis to compute the
sensitivity of the queries maybe there's
something foreign to it you could do
there but I don't really understand why
this would be the dominant turn that's
just what we saw the other thing that's
a little bit unsatisfying here is that
so at the veining I told you you know
there's epsilon parameterize
differential privacy which is this
multiplicative factor and then you can
also do
epsilon Delta differential privacy which
has these additive it's sort of slack
and and doing all of what I just said
under epsilon Delta differential privacy
would have been really natural this is
sort of what gets used in practice they
extract the things I used in practice
and you get these nicer accuracy privacy
trade-offs under epsilon differential
privacy but we don't know how to prove
the interactive above thresholds theorem
that we showed for the relaxed notion of
differential privacy and in fact the
theorem that we did prove does not seem
to hold for this relaxed notion of
differential privacy basically because
you end up having to add up all of these
deltas and some terrible and Union bound
that just kills you and I don't know way
around it but
it seems like you ought to be able to
say something of this flavor just don't
know how to do it I was actually curious
if you can also use this to
simultaneously search for alpha and
epsilon sort of because where does that
I can see bound come from Athens just as
hard as epsilon yeah so you mean and you
don't come into our area with a
particular goal of the Alpha particular
goal pepsin you just want to search him
in this space and find a sort of good
feasible trade-off I haven't thought
about that it's very natural but I think
you ought to be able to do that yeah and
that makes a lot of sense because you
come to these problems not knowing
what's the feasible trade-off and so you
know how should you know where you want
to be on the trade-off curve until you
know the trade-off curve and so yeah
that kind of exploration is very natural
if it like all the speakers for today
[Applause]